if you've already caught them all in  Pokemon Sun and Moon your pokedex is  about to expand by one I'm Tony and this  is your legendary GameSpot news update  marsh shadow is a new legendary pokemon  coming to the Aloha region it's a  fighting slash ghost type with a newsie  move called the soul stealing seven star  strike  I guess Game Freak just loves tongue  twisters anyway we don't know how  trainers will actually catch Mars shadow  but according to the official site marsh  shadow cannot be encountered in normal  gameplay details will be introduced in  the future on how trainers can get this  pokemon for their game marsh shadow will  also be appearing in the upcoming  Pokemon movie I choose you releasing in  Japan this July there's no word on a  Western release date at this time but if  you want more monster catching action  right now you can check out plenty of  our persona 5 tips and tricks  [Music]  you